We're taking numbers.
Taking phone calls at (617) 830-4750.
Let's try going to the four one five area
code.
Who's calling today from four one five.
I did it.
Hey, who's this?
Oh, this is Ian.
Hey Ian.
What's going on?
Um,
I love your show.
Um, I guess I'm like a progressive,
you're like a progressive.
Are you a progressive?
Sure.
Okay.
I guess one of my biggest critique of Bernie
Sanders is that I don't like the $15 minimum
wage.
Okay.
Why not?
Cause for some states that's too much.
Okay.
I don't totally disagree in terms of the economic
impact that would have, although I still believe
everybody should make that.
I agree with you that there are states where
the wage is seven 25 we're more than doubling
it.
We'll have a of an impact.
So I'm not totally against what you're saying
so far.
So like how do you deal with that problem?
Right.
Well, so the way I'm dealing with it increasingly
is by just making the conversation about the
fact that a $15 minimum wage, it's still only
a bandaid and it doesn't really get to a lot
of the underlying and growing issues.
So $15 minimum wage is not going to deal in
any substantive way.
Um, with the system that we have, which allows
for just like insane inequality on the backs
of working people for the benefit of the rich
and corporations.
$15 minimum wage, it'll lift a couple of million
people out of poverty.
We saw a report that it will raise the wages
of about 27 million people.
It will cause some job losses, but it's not
going to fix the fact that corporations and
the rich are able to continue growing their
wealth while every while everybody else's
wages mostly stagnate.
It's not going to deal with technological
automation.
Uh, it is not going to deal with the reality
that cost of living in some parts of the country
has cartoonishly exploded while in others.
It's still relatively modest.
So I, I'm trying to deal more with that bigger
picture than the minutiae of the 15 minimum
wage, $15 minimum wages affect at the state
level.
Because I agree with you, the effect is going
to be different in different states and it's,
it's going to vary what the, what the wage
should be in different parts of the country
varies not only between states, but even often
within states like New York City versus rural
upstate New York.
So basically it sounds like you and I agree.
Oh, great.
Yeah, that makes sense.
All right.
Very good.
Appreciate the call.
Important issue and one that we will, uh,
keep talking about.
We're going to take a quick break, but if
you're holding, please don't hang up because
we do have time for some more calls.
Right after
did the sprint stay with